My name is David Clark
and I'm a neuroscientist.
The central question in neuroscience is
how does the brain work?
I study vision, and what I really love
doing is designing visual stimuli
that allow us to test very specific
hypotheses about how the brain works.
That's sort of one of the joys, I think,
in lab, is doing that sort of design work.
We study this in the fruit fly Drosophila.
The mathematical processing
that's happening in our brain
and in the fly's
brain is really quite similar.
We have designed virtual reality
devices for flies.
These are very small virtual reality
devices that have screens on three sides.
And then we pin the fly in place
and suspend it over a little ball.
So it walks on this treadmill
and then we can monitor how the fly
is walking in response
to various visual stimuli.
What's cool about Drosophila
is that we can actually use genetics
to manipulate their brain.
We can turn different parts of the brain on or off
to see how those affect the fly's behavior.
The hope here is
that we're studying flies,
but we're also going to learn principles
that will apply to humans and other animals.
What's fun to be able to do is be able to
connect individual proteins in single cells,
move from single cells to collections of connected cells,
and then to whole regions of the brain,
and then to behavior.
That ability to make these connections
between different levels of understanding
is what's really powerful in neuroscience
and what's really exciting right now.